hey guys Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and we're doing a little
video log today because there is a lot
of stuff to catch you guys up on oh it's
been a crazy week
one of the things I'm gonna try to do
today is get this trailer ready to be
hauled I think I'm gonna go try and get
it all up and running here soon the boys
really want to fish from this I know a
lot of you guys have wanted to see this
boat up and running again so we're gonna
try to get that done so first off I got
to kind of inspect the trailer and see
what are the trailers in any good shape
I think I got a flat tire and some other
problems okay let's see you've got to
get this fixed that'll be the easy fix
those tires are definitely soft tire
over there splat I have a license plate
on this thing no but I don't have a
license plate on this trailer either so
I need to get the trailer registered and
I can't believe I haven't done that so
we had a bit of work to do well you guys
know me I am really into fishing and I
own way too many fishing rods so this
week I got a bunch more and I've got
four of these whisker seeker whisker
sticks and I am so dest to use these I
think these will just be perfect for the
boys you know more and more they're
they're actually the ones doing the
fishing and I'm just kind of guiding
them and so I thought it would be really
nice to have some kid sized versions of
my whisker seeker rods and these things
are slick I cannot wait to try these out
why don't you do it up they're rolling
around in the pollen that time of year
Nathan are you fishing catching anything
no having fun
oh I'm in the water I'm swimming alright
there we go oh good I'm actually really
excited to try out a bunch of new camera
equipment I bought we've got a bunch of
trips coming up I'm going to Tennessee
Mississippi Utah Las Vegas Japan
Anchorage Alaska Seattle Vancouver
British Columbia and we're all doing
that in two months so you're doing a lot
of traveling and kind of want to get all
my equipment up to snuff and I think
I've been through three tripods this
year they're really flimsy you know
they're like 40 bucks 60 bucks and they
don't seem to last very long so I
finally said I'm gonna buy myself a nice
high-quality tripod and hope that it
won't break on me so this right here is
a $300 carbon fiber tripod so I'm gonna
use it for the first time and hopefully
it's worth the price tag because if not
be so mad well the boats ready to roll I
just need to get it registered with the
DMV and we'll be ready to start using it
again then I can get the motor fixed and
any rate but for the rest of the day I'm
gonna be working on this Mother's Day is
around the corner so I'm gonna be making
some mother Day Mother's Day knives and
then do a little video about it so
that's gonna suck up most of today but
here in a little bit I'm gonna tell you
guys about some exciting plans we got
coming up very soon so that's gonna be
fun
what do you got in your boot there yeah
did you fill your boot up with sand well
go put that back in the sandbox
sand belongs in the sandbox come back oh
baby
your voter what'd you guys find a turn a
Peter okay yes I think I had to tell
Nathan like five times to stop hitting
the turtle shell tell me once you open
up that big package well the 9th
projects coming along really well but
the really fascinating thing is my
scooter nights these are nights on
scooters some of the most ferocious
defenders of the certain athan of the
scooter never a dull moment with these
guys so here we're both my boys who
decided to come out and join me and work
on their own projects
what do working on Tom trying to make it
all shiny and smooth and what are you
working on anything Oh what is that
[Music]
there's no the camera you trying to make
a piece of milk that's not all
sharpening oh here look at the camera
that is the face of a boy who's been
living life look at that do you need a
bath Nathan yeah like father like son
huh well we got a lot done today took
these knives out looking pretty stylin
be a nice Mother's Day present from my
mama and little Jacob here has had a
great time hanging out with me but it's
getting close to dinnertime and his
diaper is feeling quite wet so we're
gonna take you in and get you fed and
huh that sound good mud oh I got myself
all cleaned up and put away the project
and we're gonna go out to eat but first
I've got to clean the car off because
there's too much pollen look at this
look this is solid pollen
it's like scraping the ice off your car
this is just from one day all right so
we get him in are you guys ready
well he's a food well we had a good time
we drove around for about about an hour
looking for a place that wasn't crowded
and we eventually found a restaurant
that didn't have a line it was a little
far away but it was really nice we got a
perfect parking spot perfect perfect
perfect
but I forgot my wallet so we haven't
eaten anything and we're back home yay
now we're gonna go big cheese
quesadillas and eat yogurt out of the
can I don't mean to brag but I'm making
pretty awesome quesadilla yeah look at
that
let's let it get a little crunch here oh
it's working now
I bought a very large nerf gun for a
video and we're gonna test it out
Oh boom I like this thing
I just upped my tracking you yeah I'll
be careful I'm gonna burn my quesadilla
if I'm too busy shooting children and
then you pull the trigger in his shoes
but you got to be holding this button
down okay yeah well there you go no
hunting
[Music]
are you guys getting ready for bed I
want to see everyone in bed or I will
rain fire on your little hands
get into bed who wants to hear a story
Hey there was a village out in the wild
wild west and bandits would come to the
village and steal the children two brave
villagers went to a town to find
gunslingers and the Magnificent Seven
Cowboys Fox against hundred bandits and
the villager kids are in bed mission
accomplished
well I told you guys that keep you up to
date about all the fun things coming up
and we have a ton of exciting things
happening so first off in less than a
month we're going on a trip to Tennessee
and Mississippi and we're gonna be doing
a bunch of filming and some fishing and
things like that so that's gonna be fun
and then
and we are taking off the entire month
of July to go travel the world we're
going to Utah Las Vegas Japan Alaska
Seattle Vancouver British Columbia we're
gonna be all over the place and it's
gonna be awesome so if you have any fun
ideas of things we should do in any of
those places
let us know but but so far the various
things we got planned include fishing
for giant sturgeon on the Fraser River
in British Columbia doing some fishing
in Kyoto Japan we're are going to be
living it up like kings and Las Vegas
Becca's going to drive a Lamborghini
around a racetrack I found a place that
will rent a tank and let you run over
cars and also rents mini guns and
various machine guns so I'm gonna go
shoot a mini gun I think we bought 31
airline tickets here so we're gonna be
doing a lot of flying with kids and to
kind of make things a little easier we
signed up for the TSA PreCheck
and the Global Entry which allows you to
skip customs and passport control and
and allows you to skip a lot of the
security lines and stuff like that but
it's actually interesting you've got to
go through a pretty detailed application
process for the Global Entry and you got
to do like a background check and and
you have to go in to do an interview
with the Department of Homeland Security
and the squirrely thing about it is
everyone has to do it even the kids
so even Jacob so Jacob who just turned
three months old recently had to go get
himself a security background check and
had to go get interviewed by the
Department of Homeland Security so we
scheduled an appointment for Jacob to go
meet with a representative from a border
security and yep I am proud to say that
my son here is not associated with any
terror organizations has not
committed any crimes and otherwise in
good standing with the US government
actually the it was it was funny because
they have to do the interview for
everybody but they were actually really
cool about it you know we showed up with
Tommy Nathan Jacob and Decca on on her
crutches and we just trashed that place
I think Nathan like cracked his head
open jumping from swivel chair to swivel
chair in the the offices of the
Department of Homeland Security I wish I
could have filmed that I really wish I
could have filmed the whole process but
luckily the guys were really nice to the
kids and gave them lots of free
chocolate and and they were it was
surprisingly family friendly and we've
got some fun videos coming up I've got
an amazing axe restoration video that I
will be posting next Saturday and I've
got a lot of fishing videos on my other
channel the catfish and carp YouTube
channel I know everyone wants me to do a
carp fishing video I'm trying to do that
though the carp bit weird the spring
well guys thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed this little video log just know
Dan the life of the Nichols family and
we got some great videos coming up so
stay tuned click subscribe and have a
great night thanks for watching we hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you'd
like to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video